et on passe maintenant à neutre grand
invité d'honneur de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mme actionnait l'union monsois
gravité demeure de la semaine c'est une
forme de consécration non à éviter
d'honneur way apparemment d'enterrement
je pensais pas que ça m'arriverait mail
à leurs avatars iv c'est patrick bruel
le mot
[Applaudissements]
gentil gentil tout à fait un effort il a
mis un costard mais ça je suis écrivain
lalime lancinante a dit me
patrick bruel bonsoir aux
[Applaudissements]
sex symbol on l'a dit on va le juste
vérifier un truc dans public ce soir
qu'ils seraient prêts à coucher tout
suisse pour ça avec patrick bruel
[Applaudissements]
cinq modes non dit ce n'est pas
moi qui adore tenir la barre
alors patrick vous savez que quand vous
jouez au poker tout le monde croit que
vous bluffer quand vous dites que vous
avez 67 ans et vous avez 67 ans j'étais
hyper bien conservés de 27 ans avant il
avait perdu ce cas c'est la voie
maintenant il a peur du ska et le col du
fémur
alors drôle d'année quand même patrick
georges michael billy paul et michel
aphatie michel delpech sont finis
leonard cohen david bowie prins 2016
mais catastrophe pour les chanteurs ça
va vous n'êtes pas trop fatigué ça on a
passé le cap jusqu'au 31 décembre 20h
j'avais un peu le vous n'êtes pas de
douleur dans bras gauche ça va on se
passe bien bon d'accord non mais je me
renseigne c'est terrible de mourir parce
que évidemment ça fait des royalties
mais on n'en profite pas vous rappelez
peuvent patrie que vous étiez les
beatles sgt les beatles vous avez été
les buts
qu'il y avait un temps que je veux pas
manger une pizza sur les sur les champs
elysées c'est arrivé une fois way you
lie c'est votre nutritionniste qui vous
l'interdît
ya une explication à la bruel mania
c'est ça
c'est là
senna
quoi
qui c'est la foi c'est bien tu es
on dit
je te dis comme
je t'aime
alors qu'un
[Applaudissements]
mais pas à long terme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'était dit rendez vous dans dix ans
même jeu
[Musique]
mais raconte ans
/
qui a le droit
mais
le droit
il a le droit
versa
un enfant
qui croit
[Musique]
jamais
il a plu
tiéné
activée
va la vie
je tends
ma paroisse envie notre histoire qui
défilent je cherche sa main
pour pas tourner la page m
[Musique]
le tourner elle plus pauvres
c'est un champ
m
hambourg
je sais
et comme avant
dans mes rêves
quand
ce revenu à
[Musique]
mais ce fait
[Applaudissements]
j'en connaissais aucune
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'entendre ça
ce qui me fait plaisir c'est de voir à
quel point ces chansons ont traversé les
années et comment à chaque concert on
est on les retrouve on retrouve les gens
entre un renouvellement générationnel
laurentin jeu oui j'ai un jeu sans trop
facile pour patrick faut reconnaître ses
chansons on va avoir une photo faut dire
le titre de la chanson un peintre il
peut pas jouer à photo qui est
tellement facile pour toi allez on y va
à la première
place des grands hommes un point pour
madénian
clients
ils sont forts ces arméniens suivants
sont une deuxième photo kc la voie non
[Rires]
j'ai droit de jouer ou pas j'avais su
que j'avais moi qui aimais pas les
arméniens je change tout
encore plus facile
les regarde moi dans les yeux à leurs
gardes
le crétin qui dit juste ainsi que
des cadeaux
dire à dire à y placer la voix bien
bravo
bravo bravo
on fait ça aux maisons de retraite
ça te plaît pas du dernier
cd je sais je suis
gentil très bien
encore pour toi jardin
on la vache 500 [ __ ] sont là le doigt
cassé
qui a le droit ouais
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre
s'est cassé la voix un à dix on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure non mais alors là
c'est
ça se passe au à cette académie travaux
[Applaudissements]
et une chanson
exceptionnel que jacques chirac tout
seul tout le temps c'est marrant tu dis
ça et qu'on voit saab sas ou le et la
dernière très facile
adieu adieu mais sa patte sur son de
mouassa adieu toute façon c'est pas une
chanson de toi c'est quoi mon amant de
saint-jean palau un porte a
dit qu'on reviendra dessus
alors à l'écriture non seulement l'idole
des jeunes mais vous commentiez
l'actualité à une heure de grande écoute
sur la première chaîne du pays vous en
souvenez très bien en regard 24 novembre
80 justifie tout à fait votre présence
dans cette émission d'ailleurs bien où
il avait écrite pour ça s'appelle alors
regarde vous dites sur la télé la neige
a envahi l'écran j'ai vu des hommes qui
courent une terre qui reculent des
appels au secours des enfants qu'on
bouscule tu dis que c'est pas mon rôle
de parler de tout ça qui avant de
prendre la parole il faut aller là bas
tu dis que c'est trop facile tu dis que
ça sert à rien mais c'est encore plus
facile de parler de rien oui parce que
je pense que c'est le
le débat le débat éternel entre eux est
ce qu'un chanteur doit prendre des
positions est ce qu'un artiste doit
prendre position doit parler à jean
guillou c'est pas ton rôle toi tu es
artiste doit chanter moi je dis aux gens
qui me disent ça je dis c'est ce qu'ils
en disent un petit peu facile de faire
ça je dis vous serez peut-être encore
plus facile de rien dire et c'est resté
dans son coin je pense qu'à partir du
moment où on a on est un homme public
d'abord de monter un homme on a on a un
droit à la parole dans le monde est un
homme public on se doit d'user de ce
droit à la parole et pas d'en abuser
d'où toute l'ambiguïté qui rentrent à la
la démagogie des propos des artisans en
empêcher
c'est un événement incroyable
c'était la troisième demande d'anne
sinclair participer à l'émission je
voulais pas j'avais évidemment un peu
peur
j'étais très jeune
débarqué j'avais peut-être pas forcément
une légitimité pour aller m'exprimer
mais avec ça il y avait une
une échéance électorale qui arrivait au
mois de mars avec on annonçait un taux
d'abstention phénoménal qui a évidemment
favorisé la montée de l'extrême droite
et elle m'a demandé de faire cette
émission pour lancer une campagne et
dire aux gens d'aller s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales avant qu'il soit trop
tard et finalement ça avait porté ses
fruits parce que ça avait déclenché une
campagne et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
taux de participation plus plus
important que prévu ça vous manque de
plus donner votre avis mais qui vous dit
je donne pas mon avis vous faire penser
quoi de la résolution de l'onu
condamnant la colonisation de la
palestine par israël
j'en pense qu'il ya des années que je
prône que je prends deux états je suis à
l'initiative de la conférence de genève
j'ai toujours essayé de réunir
palestiniens israël ya un ensemble sur
un sur un même terrain le mont terrain
le terrain artistique soit des scènes de
spectacles ou des initiatives très
symbolique
évidemment je pense que gouvernement
israélien doit faire doit faire un
effort de ce côté là mais mais est-ce
que c'était bien est-ce que c'était bien
raisonnable de la part d'obama de de
faire ce geste avant de partir je crois
pas oui moi je garde espoir qu'un jour
ça s'arrange et que ça se passe ça
existe dans la paix et la sécurité tu es
la sécurité d'israël évidemment voir ce
soir je ne reçois pas le patrick bruel
chanteur je ne reçois pas le patrick
bruel joueurs de poker je reçois le
patrick bruel acteur de cinéma vous êtes
à la fiche de un sac de billes question
du gué
avec elsa zylberstein bernard campan et
la participation de christian clavier et
de kev adams alors le pitch basse le
pitch du sac de billes dans la france
occupée maurice et joseph deux jeunes
frères juifs tente d'échapper aux neiges
en négoce
d'orient leclec et baptiste floriales
palmieri son incroyable déjà incroyable
peut dire ça c'était là moi c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'y suis allé à
proposer ce film j'ai hésité je me suis
dit bon peut-être un film de plus sur le
sujet j'ai déjà que j'ai déjà fait un
secret
est ce que finalement j'ai rencontré
christian duguay qui a été très
convaincant d'abord par lang qui voulait
prendre la détermination qu'il avait
l'implication qu'il était par rapport
aux sujets et je lui ai dit tout ça
c'est beau mais si t'as pas de gosses
absolument exceptionnelle ça vaut pas le
coup le film tiendra pas la route parce
que ce film c'est le film de ses deux
enfants
il m'a montré les essais sur un ipad je
suis tombé c'est hallucinant et c'est
vrai que c'est extraordinaire pour des
pour des jeunes générations de connaître
le sujet les deux enfants avec qui on a
tourné ne connaissait pas l'histoire ne
savez pas ce qui s'est passé en quarante
il survole au lycée la guerre 40
il y en a certains qui font l'économie
de cette de cette tragédie et qui la
connaissent pas ce qu'il faut dire aux
gens aussi c'est que quand on ne connaît
pas le passé on ne peut pas appréhender
le présent et encore moins l'avenir et
puis ce qui est formidable c'est c'est
cet homme que que j'incarne romane le
père qui est complètement visionnaire
celui-là connu les peaux grand inconnu
les pogroms il était obligé de partir
d'urgence avec son père fait pour ça et
ce soir-là il a soit ses enfants à table
on né en 1942 et et il leur dit c'est ce
soir que vous partez ils ont une demi
heure pour prendre un peu d'argent pour
avoir un une petite carte de france
quelques indications quelques conseils
une consigne ne jamais dire qu'ils sont
juifs sous aucun prétexte vous avez une
seule est extraordinaire voilà pour le
préparer pour le préparer à un
interrogatoire et puis tu sais on a
tourné ce film dans un moment assez
particulier en attention ma novembre
l'année dernière les scènes les plus les
plus fortes recettes de la claque la
scène où je les laisse à moisson
nouvelle à un moment donné ont été
tournés entre le 16 et le 20 novembre
c'est à trois jours après les attentats
moi j'ai pris mes deux enfants dans les
bras le 14 novembre ils étaient dans le
stade mais
ils ont eu comme tout le monde peur mais
j'ai été pris dans mes bras pour
rassurer pour expliquer l'inexplicable
et deux jours après j'étais en train
d'expliquer l'inexplicable a deux
enfants 1942 j'ai trouvé que ça
résonnait pas mal
alors je n'ai pas fait fortune dans la
flagornerie tout le monde le sait je
trouve formidable dans le film il ya un
côté yves montand c'est à dire que
j'aimais beaucoup ils montent ans cette
capacité à jouer en retenue et à
bicyclette
on aurait pu alors c'est une histoire
vraie dont le héros qui est aussi
l'auteur du best seller dont a été tiré
le film s'appelle joseph joffo le
réalisateur christian dugué et la
rencontre et vous l'avez rencontré vous
pouvez bien sûr il est il est venu sur
le tournage me dire dès le premier jour
je suis tellement heureux que tu sois
mon père
je dis attend la fin
et quand il est sorti de la projection
il a il a eu des mots des mots très
forts est troublant mais c'est vrai que
c'est s était pas une
c'était pas une pression mais c'était
une mission pour moi j'avais envie
d'être le père qui l'avait aidé à
idéaliser mathieu justement vous dites
dans votre vie au site ouais ok
[Musique]
là là c'était un écrivain que je
m'adresse dis le moi je met les lunettes
vous dites dans votre livre les juifs ne
contrôlent pas le monde c'est un truc
ils font croire leur mère pour qu'elle
soit fière de ses études
[Applaudissements]
à l'étranger allez vas-y alors saint
juif il appelle sa mère et fait le
moment comment ça va l effet très bien
mon chéri a dit excusez moi je me suis
trompé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux